IT IS TIME TO PLAY ELECTRON
MICRODOPES.
(CHEERING)
HERE'S A FUN FACT: THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF TINY ORGANISMS ALL
THE TIME LIVING ALL OVER OUR
BODIES, RIGHT NOW IN FACT, JUST
CHEWING ON THINGS ON YOUR BODY
AT ALL TIMES.
JUST SIT WITH THAT FOR A MINUTE,
AND WELCOME YOUR HOSTS-- NO,
YOU'RE THE HOSTS-- AND WELCOME
THE PARASITES THAT FEED OFF YOUR
BODY.
UH, I'M BASICALLY JUST A GIANT
TALKING FORMATION OF DUST MITES
RIGHT NOW. UM...
(LAUGHTER)
AND SO ARE YOU GUYS, BUT IT
TURNS OUT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE LITTLE CRITTERS UNDER A
MICROSCOPE, THEY'RE NOT SO
SCARY.
IN FACT, A LOT OF THESE MONSTERS
LOOK LIKE TOTAL DORKS!
GET A LOAD OF THIS LOSER!
HEY, HAVE YOU GUYS...
DUH, DUH, DUH.
HAVE YOU GUYS SEEN MY ROLLING
BACKPACK?
COME ON.
YEAH.
THESE LITTLE BASTARDS ARE SO
MINISCULE YOU CAN ONLY SEE THEM
MAGNIFIED TIMES A MILLION, WHICH
MEANS IT'S OKAY TO MAKE FUN OF
THEM, HOW DUMB THEY LOOK.
IT'S FINE. BULLYING IS NEVER
OKAY, BUT WE CAN BULLY THESE
PARASITES, ALL RIGHT?
I MEAN, WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO,
FORM AN EPIDEMIC VIRUS AND END
MANKIND? NICE.
(LAUGHTER)
WELL, UNTIL THAT DAY COMES,
COMEDIANS, FOR 250 POINTS, I
WANT YOU TO BULLY THESE
DORKY-ASS MICROSCOPIC ORGANISMS.
FIRST ONE, THIS DOOFY FLY
MAGGOT.
ALL RIGHT, WILL.
>> HEY, HEY, DORKY MICROSCOPIC
PARASITE, THIS IS YOU.
YOU GOT TO GET CHECKED FOR
MICROSCOPIC DIABETES.
(LAUGHTER)
HA-HA-HA! HA!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
HA-HA-HA! WILFORD
BRIMLEY-LOOKIN' MOTHER(BLEEP)!
>> YEAH!
>> HARDWICK: SCREW THAT GUY.
DAVE KOECHNER.
>> SOME PEOPLE THINK FORESKIN IS
PRETTY.
(GROANS, LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
HERE WE HAVE THIS SAD-SACK
SALAMANDER LARVA.
KATE.
>> NICE MULLET-- YOU LOOK LIKE A
REJECTED POKEMON.
>> HARDWICK: YES. POINTS.
(WHOOPING, APPLAUSE)
I CHOOSE YOU, SALA-DERP!
(LAUGHTER)
DAVID.
>> WHEN A FEMALE FINALLY NOTICES
MY COOL FLAGELLA, I'LL LOSE MY
MICROSCOPIC VIRGINITY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
MI... MICROSCOPIC PUSSY IS
SO TIGHT.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
(WHOOPING)
IT'S LITERALLY REALLY TIGHT.
I'M GLAD THE FEMALES IN THE
FRONT ROW LAUGHED AT THAT.
I WAS GONNA BE REALLY... I WAS
GONNA FEEL BAD, I WAS GONNA
FEEL BAD.
ALL RIGHT, WILL.
>> YOU COULDN'T EAT THE
MILLENNIUM FALCON IF IT WAS
ALREADY IN YOUR (BLEEP)IN'
MOUTH.
>> HARDWICK: YES! POINTS! OH!
SUCH A GOOD REFERENCE.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> AAR...!
(IMITATES CHEWBACCA)
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, NEXT
ONE.
THIS MEATHEAD MITE.
>> OH, GOD!
>> HARDWICK: KATE.
>> YOU'RE SO CUTE, I WONDER IF
YOU "MITE" WANT TO EAT MY ASS.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
>> I WANT TO BE CAST IN THE
DISNEY MOVIE YOU JUST INSPIRED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE.
THIS GEEK-OF-THE-WEEK MILLIPEDE.
KATE.
>> YOU SUCKED IN JAMES AND THE
GIANT PEACH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, OKAY, POINTS.
EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT, UH, LAST ONE.
LOOK AT THIS DOWN-IN-THE-DUMPS
TARDIGRADE.
ALRIGHT, WILL.
>> THIS ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE ME NAKED IN THE DARK
LOOKING FOR MY KEYS.